quickly just talk about a little bit of
the news of the day um
we're focusing a lot on the coronavirus
we've just had this special session
still going on up in carson city there's
a lot of discussion about
how nevada should respond handle move
forward with the coronavirus
how would you characterize the response
not only on a local level but
as a potential congressman on a federal
level
i think trump is doing about as good as
anybody
could have done uh you know this cova
virus was
unprecedented i don't know that anybody
or this whole world has experienced
anything like this
and uh so i think he's done probably as
good as
anybody could have expected i mean
everybody actually
whether it's local or uh federal uh
you know this is all new territory here
so
learn on the job so are you you're
satisfied with how the
benefits have been handled on in
washington
how the testing has been handled in
washington
uh yeah pretty much the of course i
would like the benefits to come out more
and i'd like to get politics out of the
way
right now the bill is being held up for
political reasons and people are
suffering and i don't like that
i think we just need to get politics out
of the way and let's get help to the
people
because uh this covet virus was a
disaster for our economy
and uh we really need to do everything
we can
to minimize that and so we need to get
the politicians out of the way and let's
just uh think about the people
and uh also china needs to be
held accountable uh whether they did
this with malice or
uh or accident uh they didn't they tried
to cover it up
and uh we definitely need to hold them
accountable for
what's going on there is it
potentially if if you're in washington
going to be hard to hold china
accountable
considering it's possible that a
a vaccine could come from china there
are financial
aspects of the chinese economy that are
so intertwined with what we do in the
u.s
how do you balance accountability with
the economy well i'm sure that we have
methods and
and i don't know all of them right now
i'm sure that president trump
knows what the options are but
i would be willing to explore and
consider
whatever options we have to hold them
accountable
um we both know how much the
pandemic has affected las vegas and the
valley and the tourism industry
what would you do if elected to
um try and make things right try and get
las vegas and and
broadly your constituents back on track
and i guess more by extension how does
it differ from your opponent
uh well first of all i would like to get
our economy open
as fast as possible and as safely as
possible
and the difference between myself and my
opponent is i am a free market
type uh businessman and economy is very
important to me i think i know
how to uh policies that will affect the
economy
uh positively and my opponent is a
socialist
so he wants higher more government
more taxes and bills and policies
that kill our economy
so that's the difference between he and
i i am a free market
type businessman and he's a you know
wants more government
more oppression more regulations on
businesses that kills the economy
and uh and i'm the opposite of that
the um the stimulus
recovery money that's being tossed
around from from washington dc
um if you're talking about free market
and
a conservative approach is there a point
where there's too much that comes from
washington
to help uh the economy and specifically
nevada recover
yeah that's very concerning to me
because i'm you know kind of a deficit
hawk i
am very concerned about uh our deficit
and you know but like i said earlier
this is an unprecedented event that's
happening
happened and we've got people that are
that are just severely affected out
there
you know here in nevada that concerns me
greatly
and we have to do whatever we can within
the what whatever the federal government
can do
to help these people out right now so
it definitely is a concern and
and we need to have people in there
that are not socialists that are
business minded that
they've run businesses that have been an
executive
and had to make uh critical uh
thinking decisions and that's what we
need in there right now to navigate this
minefield because that's what it is and
like i said it's unprecedented
to be clear you're running against a
democrat not a socialist
right i think he's a socialist but
okay thinking thinking he's someone and
someone thinking
what someone is a certain way and
someone actually being that way aren't
they two different things
oh it could be but people 94
with aoc the squad aoc to leave
um there's the other ones
presley or something like that and omar
so he votes 94 with them and
they definitely are not uh
free market like i am they are
socialists
um switching gears a little bit to uh
the issue of immigration
um daca there's been some movement on
that from from the white house on this
recently
what is your position on extending or
restricting daca moving forward
and what should be done at the border
um i think that i'm agreeing with what
president trump
is uh so far what his policies are with
daca
uh giving them a a pathway forward
but i don't want amnesty i don't mind
making them legal in some way where they
can get a work visa or something like
that in other words the parents of the
of the dreamers um uh where they
because i don't want them to be deported
and have to leave their kids and that
kind of thing
but i want to make sure that i do not
want amnesty for them they can't
jump in line uh for a pathway to
citizenship
that type of thing uh they can't take
advantage of our health care
and welfare and that type of thing they
have to work and pay taxes
so i'm kind of okay with that where
president trump's happy with that
just if quickly to backtrack though your
it seems like you're suggesting that
some of the actions taken
earlier this year and it seems like such
a long time ago with
the um the crackdown on the border and
the um
[Music]
the i'm trying to say in the most proper
way but some of the images we saw on the
border this year with the people who
were put into the
uh facilities on the border you're
familiar
you mean like back in you know when he
was in office
fair enough uh i'm not i'm not here to
to compare necessarily but do do you
subscribe to that method
of no it's absolutely not it's a mess
down there
and the policies uh not from
uh recently from way back is what's
driven that
we need a huge overhaul of our
immigration
policies everywhere and uh i will be
on board to consider you know whatever
is humane
uh for anybody but i do not want illegal
immigration we need to stop illegal
immigration
and and so how do we do that well just
kind of like what president trump is
doing he's building a wall he's putting
more enforcements on the border he's
actually getting mexico
to participate you know whether
they really want to or not they are
helping
so the the situation is better down
there now
than it was a year ago or so
and we just have to get on top of it and
building the wall is very important
just a couple last questions here um one
that has a lot of impact i think here in
nevada
regarding public lands um the
the sale the preservation that that's a
battle that's been around for as long as
you and i can probably remember
what should be the approach from the
government
moving forward when it comes to um the
sale the preservation how do you handle
especially nevada
our public lands i want to preserve our
public lands for the people i'm not for
blocking people from going on them like
some of the blm the bureau of land
management has done recently or
some of what they want to do actually so
i'm for preserving that
and i don't want to you know i don't
want to sell it i don't want
uh to take these lands away from people
that want to use them
okay so then how does that align with
expansions at great basin or other
natural areas other federal areas that
have
been a sticking point in washington for
the length of the trump administration
um you mean like preserving them so are
you referring to
uh blocking them off and then president
trump
opening them back up yeah yeah
yes essentially yeah i'm okay with that
i'm okay with what
what he's done i want them open for us
to use
okay and i apologize if they didn't
articulate that uh the proper way
uh final question uh something that was
actually discussed voted on
um recently at this special session
president trump addressed it yesterday
threatening to sue nevada over the the
mail-in ballots for the upcoming general
election
do you think that what nevada is doing
is
a proper way to handle the general
election in november
and does are you concerned about a
potential lawsuit from
your the president you support you know
i'm
i'm not sure how he can sue i don't know
what grounds he could sue on
but i am concerned about the mail-in
balloting
it's very hard to do this it's very
complicated i've seen reports
and articles about states that have done
this
and they warned that uh
you know if you've never done this
before it's going to take a few cycles
to get this right
so i think that doing this in a hurry
like we did
is a detriment to our voting process
and i believe we should do it the uh the
regular way
uh where we actually have the polling
sites the early voting sites
and we can do it in a safe manner you
know i don't have to tell you
you know people go into home depot and
supermarkets every day we practice
social distancing you know where the
mass
that type of thing i think we could uh
vote this november very very safely
and we wouldn't have any issues with
that
with the mail-in balloting i don't like
what's happened i don't think they
should have passed that but
it is what it is and we have to deal
with it
um i believe i'm out of questions
anything else you'd like to add
no just uh yeah i'm running in running
for
congressional district four uh i'll
definitely be
there's a there's a huge difference
between my opponent and me
like i said i am a constitutionalist i
believe in
in our constitution 100 and
uh and and you know i believe that like
i said he is more
uh inclined to vote for socialist
policies and he votes 94
with the squad you know he's he might as
well be the fifth column of the squad
let me ask you this real quick and
forgive me for asking but and this goes
for anyone who's running for anything
right now how are you gonna debate him
how do you given the circumstances how
are you how do you intend to
uh debate him i don't know
have you talked about that with the
other side at all no no no not yet he he
probably doesn't even know i exist so
yeah no i would be open i know that uh
uh there have been a few people that
have reached out
not the other side not to my opponent
apologize but
uh organizations that have said hey
you know would you do a debate and i
said sure
but i don't know how you do it actually
so
you know me both jim i appreciate the
time uh
good luck to you and i'm sure we'll chat
as we get closer to the uh the general
election appreciate it
thank you very much